[MUSIC PLAYING]
In a place like MIT, you have
people from all over the world,
from very different backgrounds,
ethnicities, and races,
and cultures.
And the OME is a place where you
can find people that probably
have your same background.
In my case, there's one
of the staff members
who is Puerto Rican.
So that's always nice for me
to go in and just talk to her.
They're open arms, no matter who
you are or where you're from.
Coming to a place like
MIT was very intimidating.
No one in my family had ever
even been to college before.
We are minorities here.
There aren't large
communities for you
to fit in and feel at home.
And I think that it
can take some time
to find those communities.
And I think the OME just
expedites that process.
I would say the OME has
definitely made my time here
less lonely and less confusing.
At the core of this
mission to make the world
a better place is empowering
students with that mindset,
with that mind at hand
mindset, and giving them
the tools that
they need in order
to be effective in that mission.
And the OME plays
a distinct role
in that in making sure that
these students are successful.
No matter how small
you think the issue
or how big the issue
might seem to you, like,
the OME is there to
help you in some way,
even if you don't
think they can.
Like, even if it's
not academic, the OME
is there to support you, all of
you, and everything that like,
could be impacting
you while here at MIT.
For many students, they
find within the OME
that this is the community that
becomes sort of their home.
Come on back.
It's very, very easy.
Just walk into the office.
Hi, how are you doing?
Cheryl is probably right
there, says hi to you,
and helps you out.
It's just like a
loving environment.
You always leave I
think in a good space
when you're, like,
done with anything
that OME's doing for you
because you can just feel
the love that it comes out of.
The OME host a program called
Interphase, which it invites
incoming freshmen to spend the
summer at MIT, gain community,
get to know the campus, also
have a taste of the coursework,
to get a jump on
the new semester.
I recall that
experience being really
instrumental in
helping me to feel
a part of the MIT community.
The OME is the perfect partner.
They develop relationships
with students
from the first moment
they step foot on campus.
So we can use the
expertise that we
have in our support offices
and the relationships
that the OME develops
with students
to make sure we get students
the best support possible.
We have a portfolio of about 25
different programs that really
do help students
navigate MIT, but also
think about what they
want to do beyond MIT.
Seminar XL is
courses that students
take along side their curriculum
that help them succeed.
It takes a little
bit of momentum
at times to get
students to overcome
their natural reluctance to
say, I don't understand this.
I need some help with this.
What Seminar XL acts
as is essentially
an extra class for
students to attend
with a few other students.
It's often taught
by an upperclassman.
I struggled in physics
when I was an undergrad.
And I really never had any
physics in high school.
So when I came to MIT,
it was like f = ma
and I was like, mind blown.
And so I took Seminar XL both
semesters my freshman year.
They didn't just get me by.
I excelled in the courses.
I did well.
The Talented Scholars
Resource Room
is a place for
students to gather.
There is a study lounge there.
And we also hire graduate
students and upper division
students to offer free
tutoring services.
Laureates and Leaders help
students to figure out
what graduate programs they
want to apply to, to visit
those graduate programs.
It helps them to actually
go to conferences
that would be beneficial to
them to make their applications
to graduate school more robust.
Every student who is part
of Laureates and Leaders
selects a faculty
mentor, someone
who agrees to guide them
through the process of thinking
about graduate school.
Even practical things
such as affording the GRE,
like that just was not
possible at the moment.
But the Laureates and Leaders
program made it possible.
The Mentor Advocate
Partnership, the MAP program,
pairs mentors with students.
We match them with a faculty
member, or a staff member,
or graduate student, or a
post-doc who basically is
there to be a support system.
So we have this holistic
network of support.
The Standard is this
community, this cohort,
of young men who want to be a
support system for one another.
They participate in
retreats and workshops.
It really helps MIT to be a
place where they feel welcome
and they feel supported.
Momentum is this hands-on
interdisciplinary project-based
course for first year
and second year students.
I was in Momentum
in IAP of 2014,
and we worked on developing
autonomous quad copters that
would detect gases
and land on places.
It was an opportunity for me
to practice my engineering
in the team setting.
And it was also great
because the Momentum
final presentations
take place in front
of company representatives.
So it was a networking
event right after.
And it's a great way to use
your, no pun intended, momentum
from your presentation in
your networking activities
right after.
We have 16 representatives
from various companies
and organizations
who are here today
because they are excited
to meet all of you.
The OME has a number
of corporate sponsors
and supporters that come
in and talk to students
about resume writing,
dressing for success,
and sort of being able to
navigate the job and internship
opportunities.
I'm Grace Tang Wang at NASA JPL.
I'm here with the Naval
Nuclear Propulsion Program.
I am on the University Programs
Team here at Google Cambridge.
Really happy to be here
and happy to talk to you
about any opportunities
that might be coming up
in the future.
We're lucky enough
at Microsoft to have
a bunch of full-time
engineers who
are MIT alums, who
are alums of the OME,
to be able to come back and
work with those students.
I think that's really valuable.
I think it's special that those
companies come specifically
for the OME and to see
under-represented minorities
Having staff who understands
where they're coming from,
where they have
invested the time
to build a relationship
with students,
they know their background,
they have interacted with them
academically, personally.
They've spent time
with them outside
of those formal
programs, as well.
I think there's definitely
a trust that develops there.
And that goes a long
way with the students
coming out and being vulnerable,
and saying, hey, I need help.
The staff in the OME are very
much committed to the mission.
They're there because they care.
It's an oasis in the
middle of the chaos.
And it's important to have
offices like that, people
like that, that you feel
comfortable with, that just
want to help you do your best.
Because I had this access to
these services from the OME,
I always felt comfortable
going into my exams.
completing my courses.
Success and success as
the OME has given it to me
is all about
confidence and feeling
like you understand
your environment.
It's wonderful for me to be
back here as a faculty member
and think about 28
years ago, first
being introduced
to the OME and how
profound an impact
those programs
had on myself as an
individual as well
as on my professional career.
And it's quite extraordinary
and inspirational
to see it continuing
to have such an impact
on the lives of young people.
The OME and its
programs say to students
and to the world your
presence at MIT is important.
You matter.
And we believe in you.
The fact that the OME
was here when I started
as an undergraduate in 1993.
And here in 2018, the
OME's not just still here,
but has grown and has
expanded their programs.
Like that, to me, says a
lot about the institute's
commitment to
those of us who are
under-represented minorities.
About a generation or two ago
someone stood up and said,
hey, we're going to
make this difference.
And they started to carve out of
MIT a place and an environment
where I can eventually
come in 2010 and say,
I feel a little bit more at
home than I thought I would.
To all the people that have
taken the opportunity and time
and the sacrifice in order
to prepare a way for me
to pass through, for all the
professions that partnered,
and corporate partners
who all pitched in order
to make my experience
a little bit better.
The reason I have
made it this far
is because I stand on
the shoulders of giants.
[MUSIC PLAYING]